und jetzt sprechen wir über ihn und über
sein institut lothar wieler und das
robert-koch-institut was genau ist
eigentlich die aufgabe des
robert-koch-instituts es gibt immer
weniger vertrauen das haben sie gerade
noch mal gesehen an unserer großen
umfrage in das institut und der essen
zahlen also was ist die aufgabe vom
robert-koch-institut ich hab heute früh
noch mal nachgeschaut das rk ii soll vor
allem dokumentieren und informieren also
daten zahlen sammeln und uns alle
aufklären wie ist die lage was bedeutet
dass fakt ist aber genau das macht das
robert-koch-institut schlecht stadt zu
informieren stiftet rk ihr chef wieder
ordentlich verwirrung und seine zahlen
stimmen meistens leider nicht jetzt gibt
es den nächsten zahlen
das ak ii sorgt mal wieder für chaos
grund ist ein fehler im letzten
wöchentlichen lagebericht ende dezember
das ak ii verpennt zahlen zu
aktualisieren es entsteht der eindruck
omikron treffe geimpfte viel stärker als
ungeimpfte radikale corona leugner im
netz jubeln denn genau dieser zahlen
gespielt ihnen in die karten die impfung
würde überhaupt nicht wirken heißt also
dass ak ii hat mit seinem zahlen chaos
den querdenkern futter geliefert und
dann folgt der kommunikations gau stadt
transparent und offen mit diesem fehler
umzugehen korrigiert das ak i still und
leise ohne öffentliche erklärung oder
gar entschuldigung und das auch noch
viel zu spät nämlich erst nach vier
tagen am dritten januar
ja das kann also viel zu spät und
zugeschaltet ist jetzt der mathematiker
professor christian hesse von ihm wollen
wir natürlich wissen schönen guten tag
ihnen
schwierig ist es denn zahlen und daten
zu erheben in dieser corona krise
das ist außerordentlich schwer weil es
auch natürlich sehr viele melde verfüge
gegeben hat über die feiertage
die gesundheitsämter waren personell
unterbesetzt oder unbesetzt
jetzt haben wir eine phase wo die daten
immer noch lückenhaft sind müssen etwa
noch einige tage bis möglicherweise eine
woche warten bis die daten wieder
verlässlich sind und so ein fehler wie
er dem ärger jetzt passiert ist dass es
also durchaus ab und zu mal möglich wenn
man mit sehr großen datenmengen unter
zeitdruck hantieren muss das war einfach
eine aktualisierungs fehler eine zahl
war nicht aktualisiert worden und aus
den vergangenen wochen bericht
übernommen wurden ja gut aber das
problem ist ja nicht dass da irgendwie
kleine zahlendreher drin sind sondern
das ja auch die zahlen halt einfach so
wichtig sind für unser aller alltag so
wichtig sind für die politischen
entscheidungen die dann folgen das heißt
es kommt tatsächlich eben bei der
hospitalisierung des instituts auf eine
nachkommastelle an und so weiter und so
fort also da muss man schon präzise sein
das kann einem nicht so einfach mal
passieren sondern ein hoppala hat man's
nachdem man die ferien gegangen ist am
30 dezember plötzlich am zweiten januar
gemerkt oder so
ja das ist schon richtig also jetzt
diesen konkreten fall betrachtet war es
ja so dass
an einer wichtigen stelle dem rk ii
dieser fehler unterlaufen war bei der
zahl der gemeldeten omikron fälle die
wahren aufgeschlüsselt nach und gekämpft
und solchen bei denen der impfstatus
nicht erhoben worden war und für die
ungeimpften war eine viel zu niedrige
zahl angegeben worden das war dann
wiederum wasser auf die mühlen der
skeptiker die daraus den schluss zogen
mit hinweis auf die lkw garten das
impfen tatsächlich nichts bringt gegen
nikon infektion weil nur eben sehr wenig
und gesteht davon betroffen sind was
danach mussten jetzt konkret passieren
wir stehen ja immer wieder vor denselben
problemen also immer weihnachten gibt es
verzögerungen weil die daten nicht
ankommen weil die digitalisierung noch
nicht weit genug vorangeschritten ist
aus ihrer sicht aus als mathematiker was
muss getan werden damit wir endlich
verlässliche zahlen haben dem sich dann
die maßnahmen auch orientieren können
naja also was das rk ii betrifft kann
diese behörde natürlich nur die zahlen
veröffentlichen die man ihr auch
geliefert habt nicht und wenn es
lieferengpässe melde verzögerungen und
wenig erhobene daten gibt wie zum
beispiel über feiertage
dann ist das
nicht das problem des rk ii aber
natürlich müssen die daten
zeitnah
aktualisiert werden das ist auch ein
problem
in deutschland wird teilweise noch in
faxgeräten gearbeitet bei bei kliniken
und bei gesundheitsämtern und insofern
braucht das land auch unser land
dringend einen digitalisierung zug das
wäre traumhaft
mathematiker christian esser heute früh
bei bild live andere länder kriegen es
halt einfach hin großbritannien
beispielsweise liegt uns heute die
aktuellen omikron zahlen auf den tisch
dann können wir genau sehen wie der
verlauf ist übrigens mit guter nachricht
ganz ganz viele fälle viel viel mehr als
vorher aber die fälle von beatmeten
patienten in den krankenhäusern die
bleiben dort gleich also ist eine echte
hoffnungs botschafter aus großbritannien